a television camera right in front of
his fence that something John who does
not like it all he's one of six males in
the lion reserve near outis Ababa we've
come to Ethiopia to learn about lions
and to investigate a sensational report
about them we drive 12 hours southwest
from the capital many people consider
the cloud forest of kapha one of the
most beautiful places in Ethiopia about
a dozen wild lions are said to live here
in a UNESCO biosphere reserve with a
surface area the size of Berlin three
years ago a scientist - a lion then
she'd have liked a hungry lioness found
her way through a hole in the back of
her Hut in the middle of the night and
attacked two goats then science says the
lion got into the family's bed we always
sleep in the same room with our animals
it was pitch black and at first I didn't
know what was going on then the lion
attacked me you can see the scars on my
face and head I didn't realize what was
happening until I felt its claws and
heard it growling a scientist only
wounded her slightly and then left her
alone her husband said the lioness
stayed in the hut for two hours ate one
of the goats and then disappeared
Nabu the nature and biodiversity
conservation Union has its offices in
Banga the region's capital lion central
so to speak in 2011 Nabu first
documented Lions in the mountain
rainforests of kapha
the reported Lions in a non savanna area
caused a scientific sensation several
studies are being carried out on when
and why Lions settled in kava
in addition Nabu has set up a fund the
office head Mesfin Tecla says the fund
compensates farmers whose livestock has
been killed by lions lions are one of
the biodiversity component
it has importance was it completes a
food web chain which existed in this
year it balances also the wildlife
population lions and humans coexist in
kapha the area's spiritual leader EBIT
ago Toa mama explains that it would be
out of the question to drive the Lions
away let alone shoot them he's a
descendant of a royal family of the
former kingdom of kava people in the
region listen to what he has to say for
us the lion is the king here as in the
entire country he symbolizes royalty
people see their old kings in him and
honor him that goes back many
generations when a lion dies we treat
him as if a person had died he tells us
that a few years ago when a lion was
about to attack animals from the village
he prayed to his ancestors and the lion
died
the villagers then dug a hole in this
meadow covered the land with traditional
clothing and buried it
since then its grave has been considered
sacred